let's get out and say straight away that
most of what you see online that's
claiming to be deep fake isn't deep fake
right it's some kind of visual effects
of some description right people being
made to look younger in movies
that isn't at the moment done with deep
networks they're not that good yet
you know there's been some very
impressive demonstrations how much of
that is deep learning
isn't always disclosed but i'm really
interested in the topic because
i don't think that deep fakes are that
convincing yet but i think they will be
convincing
in five or ten years and then we have
some serious problems
defects usually trained with a lot of
pictures of one person and another
person
and a network learns to basically
convert them over now one of the things
about being on computer file is we have
quite a back catalogue of
videos of for example me and steve so i
had a go at this i trained it up
and it's the stuff of nightmares
yeah so they were developing all this it
doesn't work amazingly
all the time it doesn't handle you know
when the view goes off and things like
this but on the other hand
for something where i basically just put
in a bunch of source material it just
kind of did it you know that's pretty
impressive there's a lot of stuff a lot
of talk about gans and things like this
actually a lot of deep fake isn't gans
but they are encoder decoder networks
like we've talked about before
we have videos on gans and we have a
video on auto encoders or encoder
decoders depending on
what your preference is the problem
we're trying to solve is that we're
trying to take a face
and turn it into a different face right
or it's basically just trying to draw
someone's face on top of an existing
one right and that allows you to take a
source video locate the face in it in
each frame
and then paint on the new face right and
theoretically replace someone now
there's a lot more
to faking than this you've got to do the
voice the hair and things like this
right
and one of the problems if i'm trying to
transfer my face onto someone who
doesn't look anything like me
is that it doesn't look good even if the
face is good
most people who've taken interest this
will have seen this
famous tom cruise look-alike video it's
very very impressive right how much is
visual effects and
the actual deep learning i don't know
but the actual looks a lot like tom
cruise to begin with right
it wasn't going to work with me as the
bass how do we train
a deep fake right so let's suppose we're
taking person a and we're trying to turn
them into person b
so we need to first collect a load of
faces of each person
and to do that we can use existing deep
networks so for example there are
networks which will find the key
landmarks on your face
there are networks which will detect
face we've done face recognition before
and so what that means is you can take a
video or series of videos
and find a line and crop out the faces
essentially automatically and that makes
your training process much much easier
so you do this and let's say you collect
i know 5 000 pictures of me
and 5 000 pictures of steve right and
you crop right down to the face
level because if you have a load of arm
waving in it
that's a much harder generate image
generation problem which is for another
day
right if the person is front and center
and just looking like this
then maybe you can get away a few images
but if they're looking and doing this
and they're smiling and
you know facial expressions for the
network to learn all those different
mappings
you need lots more data not to mention
things like
lighting changes at different areas and
stuff right so this is person a
i don't know why i've drawn a full
person on here because that doesn't make
sense right
this is person b so these are cropped
images of faces not
not all people right um sort that out in
post for me please so the deep network
we're using here is called an auto
encoder right i often refer to it as an
encoder decoder
right because i just it's just in the
literature that i use that that seems to
be what it's called but
it's not really important the important
thing is you have
a piece of network here which down
samples your image makes it smaller
but also extracts interesting features
and it turns it into features
and this is called the encoder so this
is an e for encoder
right and we have another encoder here
now actually these are the same one
these have the exact same neural network
weights they're trained in the same way
and we have features here an example of
this kind of network is the one when we
talked about face recognition
trying to take someone's face and put it
into that space where you can just
determine who they are
right that's essentially what this is
doing this is going to be some
500 1000 2000
digit barcode should we say representing
all the interesting aspects of their
face
then we have a decoder so the decoders
is essentially the exact opposite it
makes the image bigger again
and returns it back to the original size
and we're trying to
produce another face which is an exact
copy of this first one
right so this is the decoder now what's
interesting about these deep fake
technologies
is the encoder is shared right which
means that essentially the same encoder
is used to turn a into features and b
into features but the decoder is unique
to each person so this might be mike's
decoder this might be steve's decoder
and so how you train this is you just
put in a load of images of me
you've put them through this encoder
decoder and you try and get as
close a copy of me out now if you think
this isn't an image in here this is sort
of high level feature information
so this is essentially compression right
it's it's got to
down sample this whole image into a very
small feature space
of just the most really important
information and then it's going to turn
it back into an image
and the same here it's going to take a
picture of steve or someone else going
to down sample them into
the feature space and then it's going to
up sample them back
because the whole point of this network
is you're trying to make sure this
matches this and this matches this
if your feature space isn't a good
representation of your face you're not
going to be able to do that
right so that's why the features end up
useful right this is what auto encoders
do
they turn your input into a fit into a
latent space or a feature space
and then you turn this back into the
image the encoder is a set of
instructions that take a face
and summarize it and then the decoder is
takes that summary and turns it back
into an image
and it's going to include things like
orientation and stuff like this
now how do we actually turn me into
steve or vice versa right
all we do we train this all up so we
make sure a looks like the
output of a b looks like the output of b
there are other generative adversarial
versions of this you could use right but
this is just nice and straightforward
and then all we do suppose we want to
turn steve into me
we put in a picture of steve right
we encode it into this shared feature
representation
which is you know what what poses he has
he got but then we use mike's decoder
so we switch this decoder out for my one
we turn an image of the person we're
trying to
change we turn them into the feature
space and then we use someone else's
decoder to return them to a different
face
right that's how it works and then you
get a nice picture of me out
nice is relative right um and
you know i've trained this up and it
works pretty well right it's it's a
little bit
a little bit weird wireless networking
older than you didn't believe
it was super straightforward right i
just got a load of videos from you
right which downloading them was the
slowest part and then i basically
it automatically extracted all the faces
aligned them all nicely
and then i essentially just trained it
from there and i played around with a
couple of networks involved
read up from what they did but basically
it it very it holds your hand through
the whole process and then at the end
you can put in a video and it'll give
you out a video with my face instead of
steve's there's obviously a lot of
problems with it right first of all the
networks are still not quite high
resolution enough
to deal with 1080 and 4k video you know
i didn't put enough training data i put
in quite a bit but not enough not varied
enough
if you were really committed to
providing incredibly impressive output
you would need to
pay a lot more attention and train it
for a lot longer than i did right i was
just seeing how things go
it heats up my whole house this graphics
card when i train on it so um
i was i was too hot so i turned it off
this seems like a bit of a one-trick
pony right
well actually um so deep fake all this
sort of image to image conversion which
is really what it is
it's quite common outside of faces as
well so for example satellite imagery
right people are using it for mri to try
and convert between one kind of scanner
and another
because then you can get a deep network
that works on both and things like this
there's loads of times where
style transfer which is a sort of what
this is a subset of
um is really really useful right so
there's a huge amount of research
happening not just in faces
but in other domains as well right some
of it's like this some of it's using
stargand
cycle gan you know it depends right um
but yeah this is a pretty broad
uh broad area for me these networks are
pretty standard networks that i use day
to day but they're somewhat interesting
right but
i'm interested in what happens to this
in a few years time when these networks
start to become really really good
right because you know the pace at which
deep learning is improving is impressive
right no
not at every task right it doesn't just
solve everything but you've got to
imagine that for low quality cctv the
kind of stuff that needs to hold up in
court or something like this
it's not going to be that many years
before we can completely replace faces
or other things
objects in those scenes right and we
have to be prepared for that we're long
since past the idea that you could put a
lid on this right and i'm not saying
that would even be a good thing
right so for example i used a github
repository called face swap to
do my training like really cool download
it have a go
for legitimate reasons please but it has
something like 30 000 stars on github
10 000 forks you know people are using
this in bulk right and and this is not
the only one
you can't you can't ban this kind of
technology because it's just academic
discovery right and the other thing is
that if you try and ban it you end up in
a situation where only a certain people
who already understand it
still have access to some technology and
no one else can access it right and that
isn't that isn't going to solve any
problems
like you could imagine a situation where
only people with resources could
tamper videos not everyone else and then
you've got a whole different set of
problems
you've not really got a solution and
anyway in the list of things it says
please don't use this for illegal
activities
right problem solved i mean no like
i mean deep fake has obviously been
amused because it is used a lot for
illegitimate activity
right for putting faces on things for
faking politicians words and stuff
i would prefer to focus not on the fact
that it's being used for those things
but some kind of solutions we might
think about as to how we actually fix
those problems because
they're not going to stop just because
we ask nicely right we have to think
about
you know in 10 years time when you can't
tell the difference between a and b
what do we do then like can you still
use video evidence right can you trust
anything you see
on a social media site that has someone
talking if they can fake video and audio
perfectly well
no not really right so there are some
solutions to this that people are
exploring so the most obvious one would
just be you this is a
problem caused by deep learning right
we'll solve it with deep learning so we
just take a video or a picture
we put it into a classifier trained on
deep fakes and say is it fake or not
right this is you know
the adversarial approach it works okay i
mean it's going to be dependent on
getting enough video data
will it work on the videos of me don't
know probably but
will it generalize i don't know what you
end up happening is that people are
researching better techniques to perform
image conversion and then someone
develops a better way of detecting it
and you just go like this and the whole
thing
you know it's like virus detection it's
just like antivirus and virus detection
right the viruses become more
sophisticated
they they encrypt themselves and things
like this and it becomes harder to check
and so on you have to come
up with new new techniques so i think
that deep learning does have
a role to play in trying to detect stuff
like this i suppose what i'm wondering
about is what happens when they become
so good that it is impossible to tell
the difference right now i don't i don't
know how likely that is but i would say
pretty likely given that given that for
an image
we're only talking about a few hundred
pixels across right you can
make pretty convincing facilities using
cgi already
right so doing this automatically does
not seem out of a question
i think that probably cryptography has a
pretty big role to play
you know there are mechanisms in
cryptography like mesh authentication
codes
to stop messages being tampered with
right there's digital certificates
to verify ownership of some kind of file
or
message right you could imagine that if
these things were built into like cctv
cameras
you couldn't tamper with the message
because you wouldn't be able to
recompute the signature and things like
this right
i've not thought this through right
there with people in the comments do
discuss it
in the comments right and tell me why
i'm wrong but it seems to me that
cryptographic techniques to stop things
being tampered with and make sure you
know where things have come from and who
signed what
they have a role to play in trying to
stop some of this i think
right those things don't exist in this
area yet we have stuff like digital
water marking but it's all
pretty low key more research is going to
be needed here pretty
pretty soon i'd say
cipher text that we'll be breaking later
does it honestly start with zeus as in
conrad's use
yeah the reality of random yeah yeah
yeah yeah
um you see all kinds of words in the
random ciphertext and they mean
absolutely nothing another
row of characters became
as it were normal to the paper and could
be